[Music]
spe
brother thank you so much for being here
before we get too far into it what is
your name and how long were you a sth
day
Adventist my name is Mike curn and I've
been a Seventh Day Adventist for over 42
years born and raised in the
church uh I was born in Pontiac Michigan
I was uh accustomed to the Michigan
conference those of you that are or have
been Seventh Day Adventist you'll know
what the Michigan conference is but most
of my childhood is in the wonderful
beautiful state of
Michigan my fond early years as a child
was in Hastings Michigan uh my dad
actually pastored two churches in
Hastings and Delton Michigan which is
extremely close to Battle Creek which
most of us know is very highly connected
to someone that's pretty important in
the Seventh Adventist Church and so uh I
have you know my entire childhood is
absorbed in uh kind of the background or
the or the backyard of LG white and
Kellogg which is kind of interesting
kind of
unique a little bit about my very young
childhood I remember moving to
Hastings Michigan uh we had the
privilege of of living on this this
house that had this beautiful Pond uh
behind it so we as I've got two older
brothers we would hang out swim around
in this nasty dirty
Pond
Pond trees there's Michael wow and
Dad other bird
feed so you guys having fun on this New
Year's Day yeah Doug we are all right
how about you this is wonderful yes come
join us here comes Mike my boots oh wow
nice boots dad has there to NE Tramps in
the snow my boots too Mike oh he's got
some nice boots on too didn't you guys
get anything for Christmas no not
anything there's our house look at
that front of the house and look who's
coming
David curn look who's
leaving here he comes
folks look at him
come
wow there he
comes and
this yes ladies and gentlemen this is
our house the front of
it man what else can I say
wow there's David that's what I can say
there's David
Culver he amaz go down on his sled the
amazing David
cver and then
Michael is ready to go down on his
sled and here he comes
folks can he do it oh and he hits it
almost wipes out behind the tree he goes
and oh yes he does
it uh I've got very fond memories and
Hastings in fact still have some friends
and connections uh went to Advan
education uh my entire like I said my
entire my entire early early childhood
years were spent in the Hastings area
and then I'm a PK so we moved from there
all the way up to uh we moved up to
Midland Michigan uh close to Sagen Bay
uh Midland area area Mount Pleasant and
my dad pastored a church up in that area
so most of my interaction and fond
memories growing up are going to be
steeped in kind of the early years of of
just understanding what adventism
adventism was and understanding what it
wasn't uh I will tell you that I started
in Michigan my deep love for music at
the age of
six yes Mike he's going to be playing
the piano for us he's going to be
playing Winter Wonderland I think and
here he goes
actually started taking piano lessons
and I have taken piano lessons all the
way through college uh concert trained
pianist I also learned how to play the
guitar and so music has always been
a a very deeply ingrained passion of
mine I remember when kids were out
playing outside I was inside practicing
the piano my brother and I were inside
practicing the piano getting ready for
recitals and Guild and all those
incredible opportunities that I had as a
kid while all the other kids were out
playing and having fun so um yeah it's
just it was a it was a great lifestyle I
didn't I didn't really have any negative
interactions per se um I have fond
memories of my parents um love them
deeply they they love Jesus they were
great parents we didn't have anything as
far as to want I mean had clothes on our
back had a house uh that was taken care
of had food in our bellies you know we
were just good little Conservative
Christian
kids so my Adventist Heritage actually
goes third generation back on my dad's
side fifth generation on my mom's side
and so when I think of Advent I mean
it's it's my
entire DNA it's everything I know
everything I grew up in I mean this this
was my my Norm I remember taking great
pride in who I was as an ainst um as I
got older and I began to have
conversations with friends and you know
all all of my family was Adventists my
dad has uh five brothers four or five
brothers if I remember right one sister
and uh all of them you know we gather
together in backing on Michigan Grandma
colber uh on Ruby Street uh we had fond
memories of stacking 20 25 people in a
TW bedroom small tiny house and we'd be
sleeping on the floor and under the
tables and you know and it wasn't
because we were poor um it was just
because we liked as a family we enjoyed
being together and you know every single
one that came every one of us was
Adventist and so you know that not
saying that in in any negative way at
all it was it was a joy it was I enjoyed
my my Heritage and my my
[Music]
upbringing um I will say this there was
an interesting story and I didn't I
didn't really catch this until I've been
processing some of this my dad's only
sister never really understood why she
was is
different um I remember my parents
talking about her not in a bad way but
just that that there were things going
on and she was seeing things differently
and she you know had different ideas
about God and religion and I never
really could get a a square answer on
what it was and how it really why it
mattered but I I remember very very
distinctly that she was just different
she had different
views and I remember my parents talking
about her I remember siblings talking
about her and how they were going to
deal with whatever the situation was
that I was too young to even know what
it
was but I think that's a good example of
a little bit of how I you know I I I was
very proud of the curn I am proud of the
curn name um in fact my wife and I's
business to this day is named with our
name in it we're very proud of the curn
Heritage so I'm Mike curn a CEO founder
of curn financial I graduated from uh
College when I was in in my early 20s
and um you know really pursued the the
teaching career thought I was going to
be a teacher realized as I got into
teaching that it was definitely an
overworked underpaid
underappreciated career and it it we've
got doctors Physicians dentists you know
individuals that have worked all their
entire life uh either internationally or
or or domestically you know in the Aven
a system and so I've got fond memories
but I I
remember myself just feeling
like we're we're
special the Adventist system is special
and anytime I would engage with a
non-Christian
or well non-Christian a little bit
different you would try to convert them
into you know obviously understanding
who Jesus is and in the gospel but most
of my interaction was debating with
other Christians and trying to convince
them that they're they're wrong and they
if they just spent time in the Bible
they would see the Adventist way that
was the the funniest thing remembering
my childhood is I remember um being told
that Mike if you just get people in the
word studying the Bible they'll
understand the avist truth because we
believe in truth it's all steeped in
scripture um and I really bought into
that I really believed it and I think
that many of my my family sincerely
believe that that is the
case I I I think they they believe it to
the
core but I have found that that's not
really the case
[Music]
when we moved as a family from Hastings
Michigan which was probably the the best
years of my childhood um or at least the
Fondest Memories that I had uh my dad
took a position uh as a as a pastor at
the
Midland uh Michigan AVST church and he
had two two churches it was Midland and
it was Mount Pleasant
you know I remember things like it was a
great place for taking piano uh so we
had lots of Guild stuff lots of piano
related recital um it was a a great
opportunity and a great time period and
both my brother my next oldest brother
and I are concer fre and pianists and so
that was a lot of the the stage in in
our lives where we were learning the
consistency of U getting really good at
music and so there's a lot of fond
memories in Midland but
this is actually the time period in my
early teens where I hit my first major
Challenge and it's been a challenge that
has stuck with me for my whole life um
there was a gentleman that that was
attending our
church that needed help moving out of
his apartment and so um as you know we
often would do we would help you know
individuals and so I remember very
vividly you know helping to bring uh
stuff out of this guy's apartment and as
a 13 14year old young boy you know I
happen to dump some stuff in a trash can
and there in the trash can were piles
and piles and piles of porn
magazines and that was as you know a
young curious teen boy uh that was the
beginning stage of a of an addiction
that haunted me has haunted me my entire
life
life it it's been it's been a struggle
in
that um I remember very distinctly when
my parents who again I I don't want
people to get the wrong idea I love my
parents
deeply and I know my parents love me
deeply and as parents I've got you know
my wife and I have we parents of
14-year-old twin girls and so I know
that parents do the best with what they
have and what they've learned and what
they have skills for and so I don't
there's none of this has any negativity
to my parents in any way as I'm sharing
this um but they just didn't have the
skills with the framework that they had
and the understanding they had and quite
frankly I think with the avenus system
and the theological thinking played a
role in this as I processed this because
there was a lot of
guilt Mike how come how come you keep
doing
this you're supposed to be like Christ
so there was a lot of unintentional
shame and guilt that was put on as a
very young boy and again I say that not
because it was intentional but it's it's
just the system that having a system
that teaches Perfection and teaches
obedience and teaches you know if you're
not obedient then what are you you're
rebellious and therefore you don't
really love God the way you should or it
was all this imagery all this this kind
of stuff that was going on in my life
and
so I never could be good enough and I
had
this consistent Thorn In My Flesh that I
could never get rid of no matter how
much I prayed no matter how much I
begged God to deal with the problem it
would continue to rear its its ugly head
um and I just remember you know my my
parents taking me to therapy and
counseling and trying to deal with this
issue that their boy has and how ashamed
I felt because I couldn't handle it and
I couldn't deal with it and what does
God think of me you know all this stuff
and so over time as the years went by it
kind of began to kind of go in the
background and it never was re really
resolved but the unfortunate reality is
that it
became one of the biggest
problems as I met my wife and as we got
married and as we started our family
because nothing really had
changed and so I I should give you some
other background Story I mean both both
my wife and I went to Great Lakes AVST
Academy I met her my senior year in high
school the year prior to that I had
attended a very small private parochial
um literally Off the Grid uh Academy
that my uncle owned and ran called
tamarak Springs Academy that was was my
junior
year that particular Academy was was at
a it was just north of pbridge Montana
like 8 miles from the Canadian border
and when I say Off the Grid it was
literally Off the
Grid you know my my uncle was a a a
one-time
rebellious Adventist boy who came back
and is now you know very conservative
very very much a staunch Adventist uh
some some that are going to probably
watch this later on will probably be
familiar with tamarak Springs Academy
and may have fond memories of tamarak
Springs Academy so it was in that
environment that like I
remember you know while the problem that
I dealt with as a teenage boy wasn't
there because we were so far away from
town and there was just literally
nothing available around to get me in
trouble but I remember you know the
music wasn't right the clothes wasn't
right your attitude wasn't right um You
need to make sure that you're dealing
with Sabbath at the right time at the
right in in the right way and there's
certain things that you can do and can't
do and you know all of this was
instilled even as a junior
in academy and so when I ended up
getting to to go to Great likes ADV
advans
Academy it was like a whole new world
for me you know this is like boarding
Academy I'm on my own I get to begin to
make some of my own decisions I wasn't
confined so much and of course I end up
meeting my
wife who quite frankly the very
beginning I don't know that we were a a
I don't know people would really have
matched us together per se um you know
she was on the aric she was on the
gymnastics team and I was The Pianist
for the choir and you know we weren't
really associating a lot and I remember
my first interaction with my
wife I felt like she
you know she thought that I was goodlook
and I remember responding to her in a
very arrogant I don't know I was
probably a prick back then I know I was
you you you like me don't you you think
I'm you think I'm good-looking now
that's the way I approached my first
interaction with my soon to be future
you know in a couple of years we would
we would get
married but you know without telling my
wife's whole background story and her
you know interaction with you know with
dating and men and all the things that
go on on the on the woman's side of of
this whole narrative um I'm just here to
tell you that my problem that I was
addicted to would begin to rear its ugly
head as we went to college and we got
married we got married in between our
Junior and senior year in college I
graduated in in mathematics my wife had
a degree in education child psychology
early childhood development and I had a
minor in piano performance and we were
off to be the good
teachers we were both teachers I taught
at um Georgia Cumberland Academy in
Calhoun Georgia and my wife had a a job
down near hyam Georgia at a private
school in Douglasville
Georgia you know I just remember the
early years of our marriage being very
very Rocky and it was all stemmed around
honestly the way I the way I looked at
women in
general and so fast forward a couple of
couple of years uh we we moved to East
Tennesse and I took a a principal SL
teer
position uh for the school
system and that was a not so great
experience in that again my my problem
was going to just rear its ugly head as
we got into um I ended up locking horns
with the superintendent of the church
board uh there the school board system
and ended up getting fired from the from
the conference again that's a ugly story
but I ended up pursuing my next career I
didn't want anything to do with teaching
because of the avenus system and because
of how I've been treated and all that
stuff I was still a staunch Adventist
but I didn't want to do anything with
the teaching side and so I ended up
starting a career at Northwestern Mutual
and this was going to be this is going
to be the final death blow to what could
have been uh the worst chapter in my
entire life and what ended up being the
biggest chapter where God showed up and
made things
happen I ended up becoming a financial
adviser at Northwestern Mutual and as I
as I've shared this before to other
other groups of people I I ended up
learning how to be a hero at work and a
zero at
home I was getting all the awards and
the accolades and everyone in the office
thought I was wonderful and I was the
the worst husband and the worst you know
wouldn't say I was a bad father but I
just wasn't there for my kids I was
never around and it was at this stage
that I ended up actually acting on the
things that I had struggled with my
whole
life and I ended up forming a
relationship with another woman and
ended up having a two almost two and a
half year um adulterous relationship
with this other
woman and I share that not to to make
you feel sorry for my wife or my family
or like my my wife is the most dedicated
godly woman that I've ever known and I
know that there was a reason that God
put us together because she's so loyal
and she's so dedicated and she she has
been my constant support but I'm going
to tell you as we as we get to the Crux
of this this
question um I have to tell
you kind of the the major ending where
we almost got to a point
where we were going to get a divorce um
I remember very vividly it was November
December
2014 we were still living we were in an
apartment and we were still
living in um Johnson City
Tennesse the girls were I don't remember
their well they would have been they
were born in 2010 so they would have
been four years or there
abouts yeah four four
years and we had had this apartment that
had the master you know the master
bedroom and then in between the master
bedroom was the living room and then on
the other side there was a bathroom
there's like a half bath and then there
was two bedrooms that were um adjacent a
a
hallway we put the girls to
bed we went to
bed and as my wife has told me the story
of of what happened and as I remember
you know what happened on my side of
things
um my wife told me that she woke up in
the middle of the night it was roughly
around 3: in the in the morning and she
woke up and it was of course dark she
looked through the hallway and they're
on the other side of the living room she
saw a
[Music]
figure and that figure was a very dark
figure it had a hood on it was very it
looked dark and it turned and it stared
at her and it glared at her
with these death looking
eyes and as my wife has told the story
back she literally turned to me and she
shook me and she woke me up and as soon
as she turned back this figure was
gone and she just began to like sob and
you know trying to catch herself now you
got to understand something about the
story my wife has always she's an empath
she has always been sensitive to the
supernatural realm always been sensitive
to to spiritual things and that's a gift
it's a gift of it's a it's a part of the
gift of that the holy spirit gives uh to
some people I am not an empath I'm
learning from my wife how to feel things
that other people are going through um
but she knew something wasn't right now
this was before she knew that I was
having an
affair and so she turned to me and I'm
telling you this story because not only
is it important for what God has done
but it's also important to understand
the
concept
of being used by God and what it means
to be a prophet or a propheus in certain
situations and just hang tight I'll tell
you what you're going to learn what I
what I mean by that so she turned to
me and she began to ask me questions and
it was like Mike what are you doing what
have you done to bring this thing this
demonic thing into our house why is this
trying to attack our
kids and I had learned this awful habit
because I was in the midst of sin I was
a complete
hypocrite I was I was doing Bible
studies at the ainst church leading out
in studies claiming I was Godly and then
it oh I was the worst ever just a
complete worst sinner that you can
possibly think of living the
hypocritical
life and so she kept asking me and this
guys this wasn't the first time that
she's done this every single time this
has happened where she asked me
questions I I got a fear in me because I
knew what was about to happen and this
is what would
happen my wife would begin to
shake she would shake uncontrollably she
could not control it at all and she
would look at me and say Mike tell me
the truth you're lying to
me I know you're lying to me because I'm
shaking and I I don't it's not me God is
shaking me I I can't I it's not me what
what is going on tell me the
truth and it was at that point that I
finally broke down and I began to tell
her and every time this said had
happened in the past every time I would
tell the truth her feeling would go away
she would become calm again
in and the shaking would
dissipate and this is the moment where I
told
her that I I was having an affair that I
was cheating on
her and of course the shaking stop but
of course the anger and the all the
again guys it was not pretty it was not
pretty but I tell you this as part of my
story as part of my wife and I story
because as I've learned learned what
people think of when they think of like
Ellen White Spirit of Prophecy the voice
of
God I can tell you with it without any
doubt in my mind that in those moments
my wife was the mouthpiece of God for
[Music]
me she was
speaking directly to me God was speaking
through her direct directly to me
because my life was going down the tubes
because of the decisions I was making I
was about to destroy my family I was
about to destroy my kids lives the
chapter that could have been told was
that we would have been a broken family
dad wouldn't have been around and the
rest would have been
history so that's that's the turning
point it doesn't seem like how does that
tie to adventism but what I'm here to
tell you is we we moved within six
months
um we we moved to Arkansas which is
where we're located now um we moved to
Arkansas we we reaffirmed our marriage
together and we dedicated Our Lives to
each other we dedicated Our Lives to God
and we said listen if we're going to
make this work it something has to be
different and the commitment that we
made to each other was that the business
was going to be dedicated to God and
that we were going to build our
relationship with God first and foremost
before we built our relationship with
each other we and I remember very
vividly when we moved into faville
Arkansas we were in the home that we
were renting at the time and my my wife
wanted me so badly to be the spiritual
head in the family and I just I I I
couldn't I didn't have the skills I
wasn't taught the skills in the aous
system um my dad even though I I love
him deeply my dad never taught me these
skills I knew I knew all the right text
to quote I knew how to prove certain
doctrines per
se but I didn't know how to study the
Bible I didn't know how to have a
relationship with God I had
knowledge but my heart was
cold and I don't think it's fair that I
place all of that on the aous system I'm
just telling you that this was part of
my story coming from the adven system
and it's part of the reason why I have
certain opinions about the spirit of
Prophecy and how God works and how he
speaks because I know that God is very
real and I know that he can speak
through people but I also know that you
can tell when he
doesn't and so I remember in in faithful
Arkansas in our home I I remember very
very distinctly that she was asking me
to be the head of the house asking me to
be the spiritual leader
and I turned to her and I said
Jen I can't give that to you I don't
have it I don't have anything to give I
don't even know how to
study I don't know what it looks like to
have a relationship with God and and I
so I I I don't know how to give that to
you and so I told her I said you're
going to have to do this on your own and
I'm going to have to figure out how to
do it on my own and we're going to have
to form a relationship with God
independent dependently of each
other and then we'll continue to close
the
gap as we grow closer to God
individually God will bring us
[Music]
together and I and I know it sounds like
it's a fairy tale ending I mean that's
exactly what happened
we we d dedicated Our Lives to focusing
on our the most important relationship
and that's your relationship with God
and one of the things that I did in my
Pursuit for studying is this is where um
this is where I I I made a a very much a
no no in the avenus system and that was
I took my tithe it's supposed to go to
the church right well supposedly um I
took my tithe I didn't tell anyone cuz I
didn't want to be chastised for it but
we didn't have have much and I put my
tithe money into
purchasing um Logos Bible study
software and I I began to commit myself
to learning how to use
tools to get access to the word of God
in a way that I can engage in the text I
could study it I could dissect it I
could let it work on me I could get
access to the original manuscripts and
begin to study Hebrew and Greek and
Aramaic and and have resources and begin
to really actually question and begin to
use my own brain to think
freely about what I really do
believe and so this was the beginning
stage of hey this was
2015 and since then I've began my own uh
I've began biblical Masters uh Masters
in biblical studies I expanded my Logos
library to 30,000 books I understand how
to dissect Hebrew and Greek and again I
don't read it I can't I can't um speak
it but I know how to use the tools and
the experts and the scholars that spend
their life dedicate their lives to doing
that and so I I had a a deep
yearning to hold scripture in high
regard and I didn't feel like the church
was doing that even though I had been
told listen I know I've heard it all
listen my dad was a pastor I've heard it
all listen listen Mike every single one
of our doctrines are built on on on the
Bible every single one of them they're
in the text I've heard that until I I'm
blew in the face but there was something
I I didn't buy it because there was too
many
discrepancies that that when asked they
would be swept under the rug or they
would be Sid skirted
and so I began in 2015 studying the
things that I questioned and the very
first topic I started with was wine I
wanted to know really what the stance
was on
alcohol what was allowed what wasn't
what does the bible actually say and I I
began to learn things about that topic
that I'd never heard
of about how it it can be a beautiful
gorgeous thing if used correctly and
then I ran into a text that in Isaiah I
believe it is that that actually says
Yahweh
commanded the Israelites some Israelites
to drink alcohol and how how does that
connect with the fact that my dad had
told me and my my the church itself and
my my church family had told me no
you're supposed to abstain from it it's
evil you can't touch it how come how
come one says one thing and I find
different ideas in scripture and and
then I remember very distinctly I was
introduced to a
scholar and I
owe I owe so much to this gentleman I
have so much gratitude for him a scholar
by the name of Dr Michael it's his it's
the late Michael Heiser he recently
about a year and a half ago got stage
four cancer and he's passed away but I
was introduced to Dr Heiser because I
opened my Bible and I read Genesis
chapter
6 you want to have a controversial
conversation with an Adventist read
Genesis chapter
6 and
ask the honest question about what's
going on in the first four to six verses
of Genesis chapter 6 and then if you
want to have another really interesting
conversation go to Psalm
82 what is going on with the gods and
the gods being judged and like what's
happening I mean just it doesn't fit the
framework of the Adventist system and
and I would get
these just the same responses from these
difficult questions as if Mike why are
you looking into all this stuff you know
you don't have to be a scholar to
understand this stuff it's just the
plain truth like I don't I don't
understand why it's such a big deal to
you and so I got a lot of push back but
the more I studied the more I studied
the more I realized that these people
these
Scholars that that are out there they
are really intentional about holding
scripture in high regard and so I just
fell in love with the academic
world of really treating
scripture with what it is it's an
ancient
document and so how do I understand it
on its own terms and its own context and
how do I surround myself with people
that do that how do I read books and
read read materials and take classes
that are going to help me understand
this now I'm telling you my side of the
story but I need you to understand that
just
because I I'm an intellect I love being
intellectual my wife is extremely smart
and
wise but she hates studying the way I
do and I'm here to tell you friends that
you don't have to go through it the way
I did in order to
understand the truths of
scripture my wife just picked up a Bible
and began to study it and read it and
just read it she wasn't really going
into the the indepth questions and
conversations she was just dealing with
what the text said to her and letting
the Holy Spirit work on her and it's so
interesting because she was coming to
the same conclusions
that took her a little longer because
she was couple years prior to to me as
far as study is concerned but she was
coming to the same conclusions on
important topics as we began to study
the word and make time with him and I
learned from another scholar that don't
be too don't be too stuck on holding too
tightly to your doctrines because we're
not saved by our doctrines we're saved
because of the work of Jesus
Christ and so I began to lose loosen my
grip a little bit on certain things that
I thought I had right and what
if what if it's a little different what
if I look at it in a different way why
do other people see
things and so as we began to put these
pieces together more and more questions
began to get answered that made sense to
the bigger
picture so I I I just I owe so much
gratitude so much gratitude for the
opportunity to study the word of God
with the ability to think freely think
with your mind instead of being confined
in a framework and interpreting the text
in a way that fits a specific
narrative it's the most damaging
experience to the Christian Life forget
about denominational structure for a
second and just study the word of God
and let let him speak in your life I
promise you he will move in your life I
promise you he will change the way you
think and the way you see and the way
you interact and the way you behave with
other people that's all about living
under the New Covenant treating others
with love loving God and the Lord has
been working a Great and Mighty work in
both my wife and I and my family's uh
lives that I just would never have
thought would be possible and I'm here
to tell you that my marriage is the best
that's ever been I love my wife deeply
she's the most amazing loyal woman that
I've ever met I don't deserve her but
I'm so grateful that the Lord has put
her in my life and that we're doing this
together as a
team so it's it's hard to actually
pinpoint the first time or the first
Domino um I I'll tell you with with the
way my brain thinks I tend to forget all
the
bad I tend to you know compartmentalize
all that stuff out so this is actually
having this conversation and sharing
this with those that are that are
watching actually is helpful for me uh
to be able to think through some of this
stuff and I mentioned this this scholar
by the name of of Dr Heiser and I
referred to this interaction with
Genesis 6 and and if you don't know what
that is there's a debate around the
sethite view and I I would say the the
pin prick that kind of made made the
framework crack for
me now at this point in my in my
journey I became very aware that was
what was important to
me in in my spiritual walk is that I was
honoring ing the
text I wanted to hold it in high regard
I didn't want to I didn't want to base
my ideas and decisions and my beliefs on
things that were in between the text or
that I could read into the text or that
I had extended from the text or extra
just straight up fairy tale fairy tale
novels that were made up I wanted to
know that if I if I told someone I
believe this I want to know beyond the
shadow of the doubt that the text can
uphold it and that it's not my idea that
it's backed by lots of smart individuals
that spend their time and dedicate their
life work to holding the text in high
regard and so as I said my first
entrance into this was Dr Heiser and the
entrance point was his book called The
Unseen realm which is a fabulous book
and it's all about the supernatural
realm as it relates to Genesis 6 and as
it relates to it gets into other
narratives and it it kind of introduced
me to the world of Academia I'll pause
for a second because in the Adventist
world this is this is like a no
no and I'm going to share something and
I'm going to share this not because I
want to disparage my parents in any way
okay I'm just telling you the situation
I had a a very I didn't know at the time
that it was going to be so true but my
my dad told me something probably about
I'm guessing but probably about five
years ago he made a statement to me and
it was when I was beginning to really
kind of spend lots of time three four
five hours a day I'd get up at 5: in the
morning I'd be dedicated to studying the
word and reading I was I was becoming
just a ferocious reader and if you knew
me as a kid I hated
reading but my dad told me he said Mike
be
careful because if you study too much
you're going to study yourself out of
the
church I'm going to let that sink
in because it confused me at the time I
I the way I took it was Dad are you
telling me that if I study I'm going to
uncover
things or I don't even know how to take
that
and so it had a reverse effect on me
because I knew there was something wrong
with that
mindset you're telling me that an
individual can't be intellectual they
can't wrestle with the text and actually
be truthful with what's in the word of
God and be an
avist now I don't think that's what my
dad was intending when he said be
careful Mike
because if you study too much you'll
study yourself out of the
church but fast forward a couple of
years I was introduced to that was just
kind of the first little the first
little pin prick right and it had all
around the supernatural you know ties
into Genesis 6 and the rim and the
Nephilim and the again stuff that most
people don't study in and again this has
nothing to do with Doctrine this is just
studying the Bible it's just it's just
dealing with the text and what's in the
text and so I was introduced to Dr
heiser's podcast which is the naked
Bible podcast I tell you what right now
if you have time in the car and you want
to listen to something that's going to
just blow your mind there's like 450
episodes and they're like it's just a
Hebrew scholar just digging through the
word like no one else that I know and it
just it just made me ravenous for more
information and understanding and being
honest and holding it in high regard and
so I took
um a couple of classes from his
Awakening School of Theology um I began
to contemplate should I get my masters
and my biblical studies like what should
I do and I was introduced uh this was
just last year um so about about a year
ago actually coming up in uh in early
November so it's only been probably 10
months since this has really happened
but I went to a society of biblical
literature with a very close friend of
mine
it's an
international academic scholarly
conference for nerds is what it is it's
probably the most most on this call
would never want to go to it my wife
thought it was probably Nails on a
chalkboard at the time but when we went
to this this conference together which
was like five or six days of six to
eight hours of dissertations and
lectures and just I mean just crazy
amounts of highlevel criticism and some
stuff that's just
nutty what blew my mind is the avenus
biblical research Society was there
there's a lot of other groups that were
there and so I was I was I was excited
because I I wanted to listen th this is
to to me if I'm going to get anything
really good like answers to certain
questions and
things that are on the high level I mean
these are the
scholars so I scheduled a couple of
sessions
I remember very vividly we walked into
the very first uh session I was excited
aist Scholars right this this should be
this should be
it and I walked in 20 minutes early to
the session and lo and behold what are
they talking
about LG
white at an academic Scholastic
conference about her red letter books
and how this and that and all the and I
just had
this it was almost like this repulsive
like is this what it's come to is this
what this movement has come to that
we're we're at a place where we are
supposed to be engaging in the word of
God and the scholars are focused on LG
white in fact the entire theme because
the way they do these things is they do
things for every year and you know what
the theme was for this particular year
for this last year the cosmic
conflict the great controversy theme
this is what the scholars were so every
I went through every single one of these
things was all about Ellen White and The
Cosmic conflict every single one of them
I sat in one it was the last one that I
could that I could stand and it was all
about is
Michael the Archangel Jesus and I sat
there and listened to an a scholar an
AVST scholar give his
best his best
answers and I'm not a scholar Friends by
no
means I I'm an
amateur but there were holes all over in
his
arguments not because I'm smart but
because I've just been reading I've just
been studying the Bible and I can see I
was able to see thank you Jesus I was
able to
see the
issues and so that's where like the
major
crack in the entire system it began to
kind of fall apart as I came off of that
SP conference and I was excited bought
all kinds of new books I I met Scholars
I met friend friends to this day that
are academic Scholars that are friends
of mine that I can ask questions with it
was just the most beautiful experience
ever and it it shed a light on the fact
that these
people these non-adventist
Scholars they aren't mishandling the
word of
God I'm not saying this about all okay
I'm just saying like my experience at
this event was the opposite of what I
had been told my whole life be careful
be careful what you read don't pick that
book up don't read this you know only
read the books that are you know you you
know what I'm talking about if you've
been in the avenus framework they have
to be stamped review and Herald right
they have to be stamped with the avenus
stamp and then it's
okay this was the part where that whole
ideology began to
crack and it was a it was just a slow
fade from there on and friends you got
to understand that it was at this point
um my wife and I uh we have always been
very active in the church always very
very active in the Seventh Adventist
Church from praise team my wife is a
fabulous
vocalist um she's just an amazing
musician with her voice uh my kids uh
play play musical instruments uh we we
all sing I'm concert train pianist I
play the guitar so we're we're heavily
involved but not only that because of
our business both my wife and I are very
effective leaders and I don't say that
to boast in any way my wife has has sat
on the Advisory Board to a a couple
hundred million dollar company um and
she's worked her way to that position
she is smart she's intelligent and we've
always dedicated our lives and our
leadership and our skills and our
resources to the
church so much so that my my one of my
closest friends who was an Adventist
Pastor the previous Adventist pastor at
the church that we just recently left uh
him and I started a podcast together and
it was all out of this idea that we
could wrestle with Concepts and ideas
and you know at the time I was an elder
at the church he was the pastor and he
was really the only Pastor that I've
ever interacted with that actually
allowed me to deal with some of these
questions and didn't like freak out
about it and we became very very close
to each
other but about um
uh about about
a it was about a year year and a half
after I became an elder I became the
head Elder of the church when I became
the head Elder of the church I've been
the head Elder uh for two and a half I
believe it was two
years but when I became the head Elder
roughly two years ago of of the AVST
church that we just
left this close friend of mine stepped
down in in the pastors uh he ended up
moving into the
conference and I was left leading the
entire church as the head
Elder in the midst of
questioning all of
this and it was at least two to three
times a month I was
preaching and I refused to preach Ellen
White I refused to preach things that
were not grounded in scripture my wife
and her best friend were leading out in
women's ministry putting together Bible
study my kids were involved in
Pathfinders like I mean we were we were
heavily integrated into the leadership
and Ministry of the church and it was in
this
environment that I went to this
conference and God was working he he was
working in my life and I knew that I I
had put been placed for a reason to
guide the church through the
transition but after we found a new
pastor I knew very
clearly that the work that God had for
my wife and I was no longer in the
church and I
remember is roughly two months
ago maybe three um I preached a
sermon and it's very Vivid in my mind I
preached a sermon I Comm aded that I
would preach a sermon that was strictly
about the Gospel of Jesus Christ about
his life death and Resurrection The
Gospel not the Everlasting gospel Three
Angels message thing that Adventists
like to make higher more important the
the Full Gospel right but the only
gospel the Gospel of Jesus Christ The
Gospel that Paul was given when he had
an encounter when he was Saul the gospel
that he writes about in Galatians and
Romans and Ephesians and like the gospel
and I gave a Bible strictly
scripture
sermon and I was blown
away by the
hostility that came from the
congregation because because I told them
friends it's it's not about the Sabbath
it's not about the Ten Commandments it's
not about the things that we as
Adventist hold close in our culture it's
about Jesus it's about the
gospel you want eternal life it's
through the name of Jesus Christ and
what he did on the cross that's it the
minute you add anything else to it you
add anything else to it and it's a
workspace
[Music]
system after that interaction there was
one individual that was so hostile
towards me he was sending me hate texts
you're not an AVST you're not this
you're not that blah blah blah blah blah
I can't believe you standing in the
Pulpit you should feel ashamed of
yourself like just absolute hate
okay and it was from that interaction
that I ended up having a meeting with
our pastor because he knew this was
going down and he knew what had
happened I sat in a coffee shop with our
pastor and I I
said
Rick I can't do this
anymore I I can't keep living a
lie I
refuse my
Integrity is too important to
me and and the fact that we are to image
God that is our function that's the way
Humanity has been created in the image
of God to be imagers of him in what we
do say think how we interact I said I
cannot
keep giving one thing to the church but
I believe something
else and I told him I said Rick Listen
People come up to me and ask me Mike
what do you think about this as the head
Elder what do you think about this I
said Rick I'm I'm I'm done telling them
them do you want what the church
believes or do you want what I think
what I've studied I said I can't be a
hypocrite
anymore and I'm I'm not going to share
because I don't want to disparage him he
shared something in confidence with me
that I'm not going to
share but I will tell you that I think I
can say this with enough
confidence
most pastors if they're
honest with the system they know
better they know better they know that
the system is the system they know that
they have to abide by the system because
that's where their paycheck comes from
they know it now I'm not saying this is
true for every single
one but I know some of you that might be
listening I
know that you you know that there's a
difference between the AV a system what
scripture
teaches and so I I just this is a A A A
desperate
plea for you to
just be faithful to the Lord stop stop
worrying about what it might look like
or what might happen or listen I've been
there my wife and I have done that we're
in the midst of
it Jesus said some some are going to
have to give up their mother and father
and brother and sister to follow me are
you willing
I'm telling you it's scary as all get
out but it isn't
really because Jesus is so good and the
honest truth and and the the beauty of
the Gospel when seen with the scales
taken off of your
eyes I can't even do it justice I just I
I want you to experience it that's what
I
want now what what is life like after
adventism it's not nearly as scary
as maybe I I thought it's kind of funny
because as I was thinking about this
particular
question um I'm reminded of a couple of
movies I don't know if any of you have
seen
Divergent it's like an electrical wall
and everyone's told what's outside the
wall like don't go there it's evil it's
bad like we're all safe in here
everything's good and we're happy here I
just that's what comes to my mind when I
think of this question because
everything that I
thought like things like oh you know
Sunday Keepers they don't study the
Bible they got it all
wrong I'm going to tell you a story real
quick that will relate
hopefully and that is um back when my
wife and I were still attending the
Adventist Church and this happened just
recently um one of the elders that
served under me while I was a head Elder
there um he also was singing on the on
the praise team and we had this is super
ironic okay in that we all know as
Adventists former
Adventists that um Sunday keepers are
are yeah got to keep them arms they're
they're Babylon right I mean all those
Protestant churches out there they don't
really have the full truth but yet
here's the
irony we will rent our Adventist
Church to a Sunday church and we'll
collect
money from them so I'm not sure how that
works in the evidence system I don't I
don't know I don't know how that
functions I just find it funny but
anyways there was a Anglican Church
uh there is an Anglican Church that uh
is doing very very well that uh that
rents from the church that I that we
used to attend and uh we were having a
conversation my wife was the one that
was having this conversation with this
elder and I was up in the AV Booth I was
over hearing
it we were talking about the coffee
stains that were in the sanctuary and
you know how coffee is a big nerve right
for Adventist but let alone all the
coffee St that were in the church and so
um we were talking about this and I I I
think Jen asked uh the the Elder you
know well how do you know why this is
happening I mean the the Anglican Church
that had only been renting from us for a
couple of years they went from 50 to 60
members to they were pushing 400 members
in two services and this was over just
like two years you know meeting in you
our facility
and when my wife shared that with him
his response to it is well I mean that
makes sense I mean the devil's working
hard with
[Music]
it and I literally I I overheard this
and you should have seen my wife and I I
mean just like are you serious right now
did did did you really say that and of
course the the the normal like well you
know what I mean like I mean you know
know it's in the backpedaling that tries
to transpire but that's you know I share
that because what is it like after
listen it's nothing like what I was told
you know the the anst of potentially
going to church on a Sunday and like
having you know the holy lightning
strike you because you're walking into
another building on
Sunday and I and I get the concern I I I
felt it a little bit myself until I
realized that that's just the systematic
framework of a system that wants to keep
you in a certain
position and in all reality I'm just
going to share this what helped me and
it might help someone that is thinking
of coming out of adventism and the
concern of you know not keeping Sabbath
and Sunday and that whole thing and the
Sunday national law auor International
and that whole fear-mongering that
happens um I do want people to
understand from an academic standpoint
that
Sabbath does not equate the
worship in fact without getting into
great
detail
worship did not happen on Sabbath until
after the Babylonian exile
when they went into Exile with the
Babylonian uh Nation the reason they
went into Exile the Israelite nation was
because they had broken the Covenant and
the
laws pre- Babylonian exile you look at
all of the the situations that relate to
Sabbath you won't find any reference in
scripture to them worshiping there were
three instances that required a holy
convocation totally different they
weren't tied to necessarily what we
think of Saturday in fact some of those
weren't even on
Saturday so those are a little bit
different but all the pre- Babylonian
exile um Sabbath reverence was literally
staying home and resting and not working
and making sure that you were refraining
from certain things and there was a list
of things that the priest would do and
all I mean again that's a a very very
bad overview but you get the idea so
they they were end they ended up going
into the Babylonian exile because they
had broken the Covenant and they had
actually you know broken some of the
laws and so when they came out of
Exile the the reinit Traditions that
came out of the Babylonian exile was the
1500 laws Rabbi
laws that were established as a hedge to
protect the law so that they wouldn't go
back into exile
and it's out of the Babylonian exile
that we see all of the synagogue worship
beginning to happen as you study Jesus's
interaction with the the the rabbis of
the time the Pharisees and the Sadducees
and how he's he they claim that he's
breaking the
Sabbath many of those claims were the
rebbi
laws because he's a Jew don't forget
that he's a Jew he's keeping the Sabbath
because he's a Jew okay and my question
would be are you a
Jew because if you're not a Jew that's
the first indication the Sabbath
probably is different and should be
different because you're not a
Jew so for me as it relates to like what
was it like you know I I had to come to
grips with listen
Worship in in breaking out of my way of
thinking worship is not the same as
Sabbath and then I had to deal with kind
of the whole framework of what Sabbath
is and meant and as I began to
understand that Jesus in Hebrews that
Jesus is better
than and yes Jesus is better than
Sabbath Sabbath was supposed to and
designed to point to
Jesus and so as I rest and as my wife
and I and family rest in Jesus
it's not about a day like it just be
it's a house of cards friends it's a
house of cards it just begins to crumble
when you begin to really truly
understand the beauty of what Jesus has
done and how he came to fulfill
everything in the law and the prophets
he is the answer per Jesus
is
Sabbath he should be to you so what was
it like tell you it's been the best
experience
ever I didn't get a lot of time to
actually
worship when I was uh an Adventist
because Sabbath was the busiest day of
the entire
week we still try to rest on a specific
day meaning that we try to refrain from
being busy and spend time with the
family but we go to church on Sunday and
we worship with a phenomenal group of of
Christians that just love the Lord a
bible-based church and I'm telling you
what the Lord has just been softening
our hearts in the way we just we just
Worship the Lord and we're so grateful
to be a part of unified part of the body
of Christ I never felt like I was the B
part of the body of Christ before I was
part of the Adventist
appendage that being cut off I don't
know that sounds pretty morbid but I
feel like we're a part of the body of
Christ and the body of Believers because
we're focused on the true Gospel of
Jesus
Christ at this moment what's on my
heart is a simple concept and the
concept is around
salvation the moment that you or I
add
anything to the gift that Jesus gave on
the
cross what we have done is turned that
into a workspace
system and I I want so
deeply for all of my Adventist
friends to understand the ramifications
of that what the scriptures say about
adding
to and I I I don't know how to it's so
difficult to express this in a video
setting but if I
could I would tell you to feel the
weight this the the extreme weight of
what the law requires on an
individual the fact that if if you and I
break one
law that death is
required please please Adventist
friend stop focusing on the law of
Moses do you want to be like Moses or do
you want to be like
Jesus because I have found inside the
Adventist system there's so much of a
focus in fact I just came back I just
came back is our last Endeavor and it
just this just literally hit me we just
came back from from the camper that was
in Gillette Wyoming over
60,000
Adventists the the very Monday that we
got back I turned in my letter and my
wife and I we left the Adventist Church
and do you know what the theme
was
Moses believe the
promise but here's here's the
thing do you want to be like Moses or do
you want to be like
Jesus because Moses if we follow the law
of Moses then the weight and I wish I
could I could show you the weight of the
law and the curse it is a law of
condemnation
and it pains me to hear statements like
oh Jesus came to give us another chance
to keep the law by the way that's an
Ellen White
quote that is that is
desecrating the beautiful gift that
Jesus
gave so be very very careful be honest
be Al allow God to cut you to the
[Music]
Bone if it needs be to the tomorrow of
the
bone to dissect the parts of our
lives that
this Systematic Theology has just it's
just difficult to get through I get it
it's hard it's hard to deconstruct and
figure out what is scriptural and what
isn't I get it
but it's our
journey and if you're willing and
dedicated to spend time in the word of
God and be
honest with what the text
says the holy spirit
will take the blinders off the holy
spirit
will peel
back the scales that end up happening
when we when we talk and when we engage
in the law of Moses that's exactly what
Paul
says so my my final thought is
Friends the minute you add
anything anything even the but oh but
the Sabbath but the Ten Commandments but
no Jesus Paid the
price and we can obtain eternal life by
Believing on the name of Jesus
Christ that's the
gospel and it's such good
news it's such beautiful good
news stop adding to it because it turns
into a gospel of works
[Music]